ein weiteres thema erregt sich auf oder
schockiert ich viel mehr jerome boateng
wurde jetzt verurteilt ja ich finde es
ist ein ganz schwieriges thema darüber
zu sprechen aber man muss natürlich tun
mich hat das entsetzt dass wenn er diese
frau in den kopf gebissen hat auf den
boden geknallt hat das ist ja schon ein
harter strafakt das ist nur eine
geldstrafe wurde man liest diese 1,8
millionen euro und denkt das ist sehr
viel geld eine harte strafe aber ich
sage mir für steuerhinterziehung geht
man in den knast und wenn man eine frau
zu richtet und so dann kriegt man nur
eine geldstrafe das tut einem fall
enthält nicht mal wen also ich glaube
1,8 millionen euro und vor allem es wird
ja an dass das finde ich gut ist wird
hier ein frauenrechtsorganisationen
sojan teil gespendet werden aber dann
frage ich mich wenn ich jetzt mit
frauenrechtsorganisation leiten würde
willich den geld haben von jemandem der
sich damit rein wäscht dass er mehr als
frauenrechtsorganisation geld gibt also
ich finde dass wenn es so abgelaufen ist
wie die frau ist sagt hätte es nicht bei
einer geldstrafe bleiben dürfen vor
allem er ist ja nicht mal als
vorbestraft dafür weil erst bei 90
tagessätzen ist mein vorbestraft bei 70
noch nicht und der frage ich mich ich
hadere der einfach wieder in unserem
rechtssystem aber er wünscht sich ja
nicht rein denn es ist ja ein urteil ist
kein deal gewesen den er gemacht hat das
wäre dann rein waschen sondern es dazu
verurteilt worden absolut aber ich finde
es hat ja eine form von reinwaschen ich
verstehe die gerichtsentscheidung nicht
das ist ja mein problem damit aber er
gibt es ja nicht vorbestraft mit dem
strafmaß ist es ja noch gar nicht
rechtskräftig anwaltschaft prüft doch
gerade im beruf umzug lena und es ist
auch gerade noch gar nicht rechtskräftig
das muss man ja auch dazu sagen aber ich
finde halt einfach trotzdem es hat ja
was von er spendet also ein teil des
geldes soll gespendet werden das hat das
gericht so entschieden wenn es dann
recht kräftig werden sollte aber es hat
doch was von ergibt dann den
frauenrechtsorganisationen geld und dann
ist es fein für mich hätte wenn es so
passiert sein soll wie die frau erzählt
hat jerome boateng sagt er sagte in
einer aussage finde ich hätte das eher
mehr sein müssen als hätte man ihm ohne
bewährungsstrafe sein müssen und ich
frage mich hätte manchmal mich nehme
aber auch diesen toxischen ich finde
diese toxischen beziehung aber auch ganz
schwierig darüber wird ja eh viel zu
wenig in der gesellschaft geredet aber
in dem fall jetzt also ich weiss ich es
dir geht seiner oder dir thomas aber ich
finde dass zu wenig und ich wollen die
bundesländer das sind zwei
monatsgehälter das tut nicht weh
trotzdem hatte er einen image an der app
wird ihn nicht mehr los also das wird
ihn jetzt ein leben lang begleiten ich
glaube das ist strafe genug und wir
haben ja auch eben mit unseren experten
darüber gesprochen mit unserem sport
reporter in münchen der ihn auch sehr
gut kennt und ich glaube das schlimmste
für ihn ist jetzt dass er vermutlich
auch das sorgerecht seiner kinder
verlieren wird und die nicht mehr sieht
also für ihn ist es glaube ich schon
schon extrem was dieses urteil jetzt
bewirkt auch wenn er dafür jetzt nicht
im knast sitzt oder andere strafen
erhält also ich glaube das ist schon
extrem
[Musik]